H
S
AR
NC
BIDEN'S FATHER STAY ON TOP?
WELL, HE DIDN'T.
AND THAT'S ANOTHER STORY FOR
ANOTHER DAY.
THE BIDEN FAMILY BALANCE SHEET
HAS ALWAYS BEEN FULL OF
QUESTIONABLE DETAILS.
BUT THE MEDIA DOESN'T CARE TO
LOOK INTO IT BECAUSE IT DESTROYS
THEIR NARRATIVE.
BIDEN IS JUST A PROTECT THEY
SOLD TO BEAT TRUMP.
AND NOW THAT PRODUCT, JOE BIDEN
IS DECTIVE AND THEY ARE
STARTING TO PULL HIM FROM THE
SHELVES.
YOU REMEMBER.
THEY TOLD US BIDEN WAS CALM,
COOL AND COLLECTED.
AND A WISE MAN WITH A STEADY
HAND.
BUT HE HAS SHOWN US THAT HE IS
ANYTHING BUT.
LISTEN TO HOW HE TALKS ABOUT HIS
SON HUNTER COMPARE TO AN ACTUAL
PROFESSIONAL.
>> HE IS THE SMARTEST MAN I
KNOW.
I MEAN, PURE INTELLECTUAL
CAPACITY.
>> POLITICAL LIABILITY TO HAVE
HIM IN THE MIDTERMS.
>> THAT'S A GREAT ASSET.
MORE INFLATION.
WHAT A STUPID SON OF A BITCH.
>> Jesse: CALM DOWN.
HUNTER IS THE SMARTst MAN YOU
KNOW BUT PET DOOCY IS A STUPID
SON OF A BITCH:  WE GET IT BUT
THIS IS WHO BIDEN IS A CORNERED
GRUMP WITH A SUSPECT RESUME.
MAYBE DR. JILL CAN GIVE US SOME
INSIGHT INTO WHY HE IS SO
CRANKY.
MAYBE IT'S MANCHIN AND SINA
DRIVIN HIM NUTS OR MAYBE HE
JUST CAN'T HANDLE KAMALA'S
CONSTANT DRAMA, WE CAN'T EITHER.
EITHER WAY, BIDEN IS LOSING HIS
TEMPER FAR MORE OFTEN THAN
NORMAL.
>> ASK THE RIGHT QUESTION.
>> DAMN LIAR, MAN.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> WHY THE HELL WOULD TAKE A
TEST?
COMMON, MAN.
>> WHAT THE HELL WHAT DO YOU ALL
THE TIME?
GOVERNMENTAL BACK AND READ WHAT
I SAID!
THAT IS AN INTERESTING READING
OF ENGLISH.
>> Jesse: AS THE MEDIA BENDS
OVER BACKWARDS TRYING TO COVER
FORIDEN, IS HE SNAPPING AT
THEM.
I GUESS THE OLD SAY SOMETHING
TRUE FOR THE LEFT WING MEDIA,
SOMETIMES IT'S THE ONES YOU LOVE
WHO HURT YOU THE MOST.
BUT JOE IS CLEARLY FRUSTRATED.
AND YOU WOULD BE, TOO IF YOU
LOST TOTAL CONTROL OF YOUR
PRESIDENCY.
REMEMBER BACK IN MARCH WHEN HE
SAID THIS ABOUT PUTIN?
>> WE HAD A LONG TALK, HE AND I.
I KNOW HIM RELATIVELY WELL.
AND I -- THE CONVERSATION
STARTED OFF, I SAID I KNOW YOU
AND YOU KNOW ME.
JESS YES, SIR FLASH FORWARD TO
JUST LAST WEEK.
>>'M NOT SO SUR HE HAS --
CERTAIN WHAT HE IS GOING TO DO.
MY GUESS IS HE WILL MOVE I
HE HAS TO DO SOMETHING.
>> Jesse: BIDEN DOESN'T
UNDERSTA PUTIN.
HE HAS NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING ON.
SO THIS IS A LESSON.
WHATEVER THE CORPORATE MEDIA
TELLS YOU IT'S PROBABLY JUST A
SALES PITCH FOR A PRODUCT THEY
ARE MAKING MONEY FROM ON THE
BACK END.
IHINK YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT, DON'T YOU?
CHINA, PFIZER, FACEBOOK,
UKRAINE, OPEN BORDERS.
YOU FOLLOW THE MONEY, AND WORK
BACK FROM THERE.
WE'RE PUTTING IT TOGETHER.